PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
TODAY IS TUESDAY JULY.
TO NINE TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
WILL HELP QUORUM WAS PROCEED AS
A SUB COMMITTEE I SEE SENATOR
ALLEN AND JOINING US -- WELCOME
SENATOR ALLEN YOU HAVE -- ITEM
SB.
SIX SIX FOUR ANYTIME YOU'RE
READY.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
US SIX SIXTY FOUR WHICH WHICH
OFFERS A CALPERS REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES HAVE
CLEAR AUTHORITY TO RESPONSIBLE
USE PERSONAL INFORMATION. FOR
NECESSARY DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES
TO OPERATE TOOLS AND REGIONAL
TRANSIT SYSTEMS ON THE PUBLIC'S
BEHALF.
I WANT THE TO COMMITTEE I THANK
THE CHAIR -- THE EXCELLENT STAFF
FOR THE PHONE CALLS THE EMAILS
THE MARATHON STAKEHOLDER MEETING.
THAT PREDATES -- MY PRESENTATION
THE BILL HERE TODAY -- AND I
ALSO WANT TO THINK ON OPPOSITION
AND SUPPORTERS A MINUTE WE WE'VE
I THINK AT A VERY PROGRESS
PRODUCTIVE.
CONVERSATION -- WE HAVE -- AN
EXTENSIVE ARRAY OF AMENDMENTS
LAID OUT BETWEEN PAGES.
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS
AND I'M ACCEPTING ALL OF THEM.
HI VA WOULD SUBSTANTIALLY NARROW
SB SIX SIXTY FOUR NUMBER
SIGNIFICANT WAYS AND I I WILL
SAY I THINK APPROPRIATELY SO --
EVEN THOUGH SOME AYE SUPPORTERS
MEN AND GREAT -- YOU KNOW AS THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS CALIFORNIA
AUTHORIZES REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO BUILD
OPERATE AND MAINTAIN ROADS
BRIDGES AND TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND PROVIDE SERVICES ON BEHALF
OF THE PUBLIC I AM BEFORE YOU
WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE A GROWING
LIST.
OF LITIGANTS SOME PETITIONING
FOR CLASS ACTION STATUS OF FILED
CLAIMS AGAINST MANY REGIONAL
TOLL AGENCIES AND CONTRACTORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALLEGING
VIOLATIONS IMPERIL.
LILY BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER TALKS
FOR DOLLARS -- PLEASE ARGUING
THERE BEEN MILLIONS OF
VIOLATIONS.
OF STREETS AND HIGHWAYS CODE
SECTION THIRTY ONE FOR NINETY
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED.
IN TWENTY TEN THROUGH
LEGISLATION AUTHORED BY CENTER
JUST MEDIAN WHICH IS SB.
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT NOW THE WELL
DOCUMENTED INTENT OF CENTERS
MILLIONS BILL AND I THINK I HAVE
HIS FACT SHEET.
FROM DEEP IN THE HISTORY OF
TWENTY TEN HERE IN THE WELL BUT
FOR THE WELL DOCUMENTED INTENT
WAS TO CODIFY UNIFORM STANDARDS.
ACROSS ALL CALIFORNIANS TOLLING
AGENCIES TO PROTECT AGAINST
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION CONSUMERS.
BEING PROVIDED TO COMPANIES
ORGANISATIONS FOR MARKETING OR
INAPPROPRIATE USES.
A CENTER SEAT MEDIAN FACT SHEET
ACTUALLY DETAILS HOW THE BILL
WAS CRAFTED EXPLICITLY SO THAT.
IT WOULD NOT HINDER A
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FROM
FINANCIAL ACTIVITIES REQUIRED TO
OPERATE AND MANAGE TOLL
FACILITIES.
INCLUDING THE SHARING OF DATA TO
ENSURE INTER OPERABILITY OF TOLL
COLLECTION DEVICES AND
TECHNOLOGIES.
IN THE MIDST OF ONGOING
LITIGATION A CERTAIN PROVISIONS
OF SB SIX SIXTY FOUR WOULD APPLY
RETROACTIVELY.
AND THE SECTIONS DESERVE I THINK
VERY CAREFUL SCRUTINY -- BY ALL
OF THE ALL OF US TO ENSURE THAT
OUR INTENT IN GRANTING
RETROACTIVITY.
IS TRULY IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
A SERIES CONSUMER INJURIES CAN
AND DO OCCUR WHEN SENSITIVE AND
PRIVATE INFORMATION IS SHARED
FOR MARKETING OR INAPPROPRIATE
SERVICES -- BUT YOU KNOW THE
OTHER DAY.
THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL AND AND
THE VERY NARROW LANGUAGE THE
BILL ESPECIALLY NOW WITH THESE
WITH THESE I THINK VERY WELCOME
A MAN'S.
I MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL DOES
NOT LOOSEN PROTECTIONS WHICH
GUARD AGAINST THE MISUSE OF DATA
IT PRESERVES EXISTING
PROHIBITIONS ON SALE OR
DISCLOSURE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION UNCONNECTED.
WITH OPERATING TOLL FACILITIES
IN TRANSIT PAYMENT SYSTEMS.
BUT THE LEGISLATION ALSO
RESPONSIBLY DEFENDS THE VITAL
PUBLIC INTEREST IN THE OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE.
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT DOES INCLUDE.
ARE YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE PAY.
ARE THERE TOLLS.
ABSENT CLEAR EVIDENCE THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE BETTER OFF IF
BILLIONS OF TAX DOLLARS ARE
IMPERILED.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT
NECESSARY CLARIFICATION OF STATE
LAW TO INCLUDE.
I STARTED TO CONTINUE ALLOWING
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO USE
PERSONAL DATA EFFICIENTLY FOR
THINGS LIKE.
YEP PASS IT ON THE ADDRESS SO AS
TO BE ABLE -- TO SEND A NOTICE
OF TOLL -- WHILE AT THE SAME
TEAM MAINTAINING APPROPRIATE
PROHIBITIONS AGAINST IMPROPER
SHARING OF THAT INFORMATION.
I I I REALLY DO REITERATE THE
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE ON THIS --
I EVEN WHEN I FIRST TOOK THE
BILL AND I HI AND AND I I SAW
HOW THINGS WERE LINING UP I
MYSELF WAS.
REALLY CONCERNED LOOKING FOR TO
THE WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE TO TO
ENSURE.
THAT WE REALLY KEPT THIS
NARROWLY FOCUSED.
ON ON ON ALLOWING THE AGENCIES
TO DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
THAT'S COOL THAT THEY'RE CLEAR
ALLOWED TO DO.
WE SEND THE INTENT OF THE
CIVILIAN BILL WHILE NOT ALLOWING
ANY MORE ANY ANY ADDITIONAL --
YOU KNOW ANYTHING MORE THAN THAT.
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
THERE WITH THESE MEN CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS -- AS THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD I WITH
ME I HAVE SEVERAL JOHNSON IS THE
CHIEF TOLL OPERATIONS OFFICER
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION QUARTER
AUTHORITIES.
OF ORANGE COUNTY IS ALSO CHAIR
THE TRICK CALIFORNIA TOLL
OPERATORS COMMITTEE AND ALSO
MORE TOP WAS HERE ON BEHALF OF
AN ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY I I KNOW ALSO WE'VE
GOT -- TO HELP WITH LEGAL AND
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS BEEN RUBIN.
WHO IS WITH THE TRANSMISSION
COURT OR IT THOR IT AGENCIES OF
ORANGE COUNTY?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR SOME
IN THIS PLACE.
WHICH JOHNNY MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX SIXTY FOUR AS CENTER ALLEN
NOTED MY NAME IS SAMUEL JOHNSON.
CHIEF TOLD OPERATIONS OFFICER
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION CORPS
AGENCIES IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA.
I AM THE INCOMING CHAIR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BRIDGE TUNNEL AND
TURNPIKE ASSOCIATION SERVING TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY MEMBERS ACROSS
TWENTY THREE COUNTRIES.
I ALSO SERVE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TOLD OPERATORS
COMMITTEE OR C. TOPPED.
SEATAC IS THAT.
COALITION OF THE FOURTEEN PUBLIC
AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR TOLLING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- IN ACCORDANCE WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW THE MEMBERS OF
SEE TOP WORK CLOSELY WITH
CALTRANS IN DEVELOPING OUR
SPECIFICATIONS ON HOW TO
EXCHANGE DATA. TO ENSURE THAT WE
ACHIEVED IN OUR ABILITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND TO MAKE
SURE CUSTOMERS WERE PROPERLY
BUILD IN CHARGE FOR THE USE OF
TOLL FACILITIES.
I WAS ARE MYSELF ALONG WITH
OTHER MEMBERS OF SEE TIME WERE
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN WORKING
WITH SENATORS MEDIA IT'S OFFICE
IN CRAFTING THE LANGUAGE AND SB.
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT TO ENSURE THE
PROPER HANDLING OF PERSONAL DATA
AND THAT THE TOLL I AGENCIES
COULD OPERATE AS THEY DO DAILY.
SEE TALK ALSO WORKS WITH THE DMV
UTILIZING THEIR STANDARDS FOR
IDENTIFYING VEHICLE OWNERS AND
ENFORCING THE PAYMENT OF TOLLS.
TOLD AGENCIES HAVE IT HERE TO
THE LAW AND ITS INTENT HAS
EXPRESSED BY SENATORS MEDIAN AND
THERE BEEN NO BREACHES OF
PRIVACY SALES OF CUSTOMER DATA.
OR NO CONSUMER HARM FROM THE
AGENCIES TOWING OPERATIONS HAVE
OCCURRED.
HOWEVER CLARIFICATIONS IN THE
LAW ARE NEEDED TO COMBAT FALSE
ASSERTIONS AROUND MISCONCEIVED
GRAY AREAS.
THESE ASSERTIONS CALL INTO
QUESTION OUR DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS -- AND OUR DAILY
PRACTICES OF OUR AGENCIES AND
THREATEN OUR MEMBERS WITH
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND FINES FOR DOING SUCH THINGS
AS COMMUNICATING WITH THE DMV TO
GET THE REGISTERED -- THE RICH
SHOULD OWNERS ADDRESS AND
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN
PROBABLY NOTICED THEM REGARDING
AN UNPAID TOLL.
COMPLYING WITH THE STATE MANDATE
FOR INTER OPERABILITY BY SHARING
INFORMATION BETWEEN TOLL
AGENCIES TO PROPERLY BILL
CUSTOMERS. FOR USING THE US
POSTAL SERVICE FOR MAILING
NOTICES TO CUSTOMERS. FOR USING
VENDORS TO SUPPORT OUR SYSTEMS
AND PROCESS TOLLS.
AND AND AS A TRUE DICHOTOMY --
PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS ARE
CLAIMING WE VIOLATE THE LAW WHEN
WE CONDUCT THE SKIP TRACE TO
TRYING TO GET A CORRECT ADDRESS
FOR SOMEONE.
BUT YET THEY ALSO CLAIM WE
VIOLATE THE LAW WHEN WE DON'T DO
A SKIP TRACE TO TRY AND IDENTIFY
THE CORRECT ADDRESS.
OF SOMEONE WHO HASN'T PAID THEIR
TOLL.
SO SB SIX SIXTY FOUR WOULD CLEAR
UP THESE GRAY AREAS AND CODIFIED
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE LAW.
WHILE RETAINING PROTECTIONS FOR
PRIVACY.
ALLOWING US TO PERFORM OUR DAILY
FUNCTIONS THAT ARE BEST
PRACTICES IN THE TOLLING A TREE.
THIS BILL SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF TOLLING AS A
VIABLE REVENUE SOURCE USED TO
ENHANCE MOBILITY.
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM AND IMPROVE
TRANSIT OPERATIONS AS WELL AS
SUPPORT CRITICAL SAFETY
FUNCTIONS PERFORMED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
IN CLOSING WE APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR -- FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS
CAN CRAFTING REASONABLE
AMENDMENTS HOW WE FEEL LIKE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
PRODUCTIVELY TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION CONCERNS WE SCALE
BACK THE RETROACTIVITY VERBIAGE.
IN NARAL THE BILL TO CLARIFY THE
ISSUES AROUND CENTERS MEDIANS
ORIGINAL BUILDING HIS INTENT.
SO ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
CALIFORNIA TOLD AGENCIES I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BEFORE WE GO TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS A LIKE TEST LABS CHAU
QUORUM AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CHAU AIR CHAO HERE KILEY.
BARRICADE CAN.
POWER CAN HEAR HER BERMAN
CALDERON.
CALDERON HERE GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER HERE.
IRWIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE HERE SMITH.
SMITH HERE WICKS HERE WICKS HERE.
I ALSO LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO APPROVE TODAY SO
CONSENT.
A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
FILE ITEM THREE S. C. R. FORTY
FOR THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
CHAO HI CHAO AYE AYE KILEY.
OUR QUE HAN.
POWER QUE HANNAH I BERMAN.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I IRWIN -- WHEN I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE SMITH?
SMITH I WICKS.
WICKS HI THE BILL IS OUT AS C.
R. FORTY FOUR EIGHT ZERO OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M I'M WHERE A TOP ARE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB.
SIX SIX FOUR AS NOTED SB SIX SIX
FOR THE CLARIFICATION BILL --
THAT WE BELIEVE IS A CRITICAL TO
PRESERVE THE ABILITY FOR TOLL
OPERATORS ACROSS THE STATE TO
MEET IN OUR OPERABILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND FORCE TOLL
POLICIES.
INITIAL VIOLATIONS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
ALL WITHOUT WEAKENING EXISTING
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR THE USE
OF PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION.
SB SIX SIX FOUR WILL ALSO ENSURE
THAT TOLL OPERATORS SUCH AS
THEIR CTA CAN CONTINUE TO
EQUITABLY ENFORCED TOLL POLICIES
INCLUDING WHEN RENTAL WHEN USING
THE USE WHEN USING -- RENTAL
CARS ARE USING THE FACILITIES OR
WHEN A DRIVERS USING A
TRANSPONDER TRANSPONDER PROVIDED
BY A TOLL OPERATOR IN ANOTHER
PART OF THE STATE WHICH ARE BOTH
REQUIREMENTS OF STATE LAW OFF
UPON US.
WITHOUT THESE CLARIFICATIONS
TOLL FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
I WILL BE SUBJECT TO LITIGATION
CHALLENGES THAT COULD DISRUPT
THE VIABILITY OF EXISTING AND
FUTURE TOLL FACILITIES.
AND THREATEN THE ABILITY OF TOLL
AGENCIES TO USE EXCESS TOLL
REVENUES TO INVEST IN ADDITIONAL
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS AND
TRANSIT SUBSIDIES.
IT'S A CHAIRMAN WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE -- THE TIME YOU AND
YOUR STAFF HAS SPENT WORKING ON
THIS BILL -- AS NOTED THE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN THE
MOCK UP IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NARROW THE BILL WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THEM BEING VERY
SURGICAL AMENDMENTS THAT HEN WE
WE THINK THAT THAT THEY HOUND
THE BILL TO THE CRITICAL AND
MOST IMPORTANT PIECES.
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS THE
PASSAGE OF SB SIX SIX FOUR WILL
MAINTAIN EXISTING CONSUMER
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THAT TOLL OPERATORS CAN
SHARE NECESSARY INFORMATION WITH
EACH OTHER TO COMPLY WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL IN OUR OPERABILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
IMPROVE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
AND FACIL AND FAT AND FACILITY
EFFICIENCY.
AND MAXIMIZE THE USE OF REVENUES
FOR REINVESTMENT AND FURTHER
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS WE
ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL UNTIL HERE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED WEST RIVA
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
RICHARD HARRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY -- WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTER INTO A
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION.
AUTHORITY WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
ONLY KNOW THAT -- LA METROS
EXPRESS LANES PROGRAM IS THE
ONLY A TOLL PROGRAM THE STATE
ACTUALLY HAS AN EQUITY PROGRAM
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUTERS.
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION --
PROGRAM IS LINKED TOWARDS THE
TRANSIT PASSES THAT WOULD
PROVIDE.
AND SO IT MAKES IT ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO KIND OF GET
A SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM --
RIGHT ALSO ADD THAT -- EXCESS
TOLL REVENUE AND THE TO PARTS OF
THE FREEWAY SYSTEM IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THAT WE OPERATE
THE TOLL LANES.
IS INVESTED IN TRANSIT AND OTHER
PROJECTS IN THE QUARTER.
THANK YOU MAY LOSE OF IMPORTANT
LINCOLN WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANKS MUCH THANKS PLEASE.
THE STRUCTURE MEMBERS THE BAKER
WITH THEIR IN ASSOCIATES FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
REMEMBER TRUST BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
SAME PER DAY HOW CAN I
TRANSPORTATION THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE GET
YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MONNA GONNA BE
HALF THE BAY AREA TOLL AUTHORITY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLACE.
MR MEMBERS GREG HAYES ON BEHALF
OF NAY ELEGY HEADQUARTERED IN
SAN DIEGO THE LEADING TELLING
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDER IN THE
COUNTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS --
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL POLICE
ARE STILL
.
FOR WELCOME ANYTIME YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BACK AYE
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITTEE ON
THE AUTHOR'S WORKS TO ADDRESS A
FEW OF OUR CONCERNS HOWEVER WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BELL -- AS
WILL BE AMENDED IN THIS
COMMITTEE -- I'M A PUT ASIDE THE
QUESTIONS AROUND -- WHETHER OF
THE LIABILITY AND RETROACTIVITY
ISSUES -- BECAUSE SOMEONE ELSE
WILL BE ADDRESSING AS AN I'M
GONNA FOCUS MY TESTIMONY SOLELY
ON THE QUESTION OF WHETHER.
THE POLICY CHANGES CONTEMPLATED
AND THE SPELL ARE GOOD POLICY
GOING FORWARD AND THE CLEAR
ANSWER IS NO THEY ROLL BACK
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AND REYES
SIRIUS DUE PROCESS CONCERNS.
LOOKING JUST AT THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS IN SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL UNDER SUBDIVISION I THE
SUBDIVISION -- THAT CHANGES
WOULD EXPAND THE PERMISSIBLE --
REASONS FOR SHARING DATA FROM
FINANCIAL AND ACCOUNTING
FUNCTIONS REQUIRED TO OPERATE
AND MANAGE THE TOLL COMPANIES TO
ANY OPERATING AND MANAGEMENT
PURPOSE WHICH LEAVES OPEN THE
ABILITY.
TO UNDER THIS BILL PERMISSIBLE
YOU SHARE ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION WITH EVERYONE FROM
JANITORS TO BIG DATA AS LONG AS
THOSE AGENT THOSE ENTITIES.
RELATE IN SOME WAY TO THE
OPERATING OR MANAGEMENT OF THE
TOLL COLLECTION AGENCY WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S REAL THERE IF THEY
HAVE ANY LEGITIMATE NEED FOR
THIS DATA.
MOVING ON TO SUBDIVISION J. --
THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD QUALIFY
THE WRITTEN CONSENT REQUIRED
PRIOR TO SENDING MARKETING
MATERIALS IT UNDER THIS BILL IT
WOULD BE QUALIFIED SO THAT YOU
WOULD ONLY NEED THIS WRITTEN
CONSENT. FOR INFORMATION
ACQUIRED ON OR BEFORE JANUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN MEANING THAT
IF A TOLL AGENCY HAS SOMEONE
SCHEME OUT FOR EXAMPLE THAT THEY
ACQUIRED ON DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND TEN THEY
CAN EMAIL MARKETING MATERIALS
WITHOUT ANY WRITTEN CONSENT. TO
THAT PERSON UNDER THIS BELL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED IN THE
AMENDMENTS.
MOVING ON LOOKING AT THE ENTIRE
SECTION OF SECTION ONE IT'S ALL
ABOUT WHEN AND WHY
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES CAN
SHARE PRIVATELY IDENTIFIED.
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION WITH
ANOTHER ENTITY AND SO THE
CHANGES IN SUBDIVISION AL TO THE
DEFINITION OF TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY TO INCLUDE ANY CONTRACTOR.
ISN'T A HUGE LOOPHOLE.
BECAUSE IT WOULD ALLOW A TOLL
COLLECTION AGENCY TO GET AROUND
ALL OF THE REASONABLE DATA
SHARING RESTRICTIONS IN THIS
SECTION.
ON COMPLETELY UNDERMINES THE
ENTIRE INTENT OF THE STATUTE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE THINK THAT
THE SPELL THE POLICY MOVING
FORWARD -- IN ADDITION TO ALL OF
THE CONCERNS AROUND THE ODD.
RETROACTIVITY AND THE DUE
PROCESS AND PUBLICATIONS WE
THINK THIS IS BAD POLICY FOR
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR NOTE OF IT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT WHEN HIS
PLACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THE MEMBERS MY NAME'S BLAKE WHEN
THE MEN I REPRESENT A CERTIFIED
CLASS OF DRIVERS IN CALIFORNIA --
WE BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
GO -- TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL SEVERAL
ISSUES WITH THIS BILL ARE
HARMFUL.
FIRST AND FOREMOST A SUBSECTION
T. WHICH DEALS WITH THE FACT
THAT THIS WOULD BE DECLARATORY
OF EXISTING LAW.
THE AMENDMENTS TO THAT MY
COLLEAGUE JUST DISCUSS GO FAR
AND BEYOND A WATER DECLARE
TOWARD EXISTING LAW AND AND HAVE
THE REAL ABILITY TO IMPERIL THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS OF CONSUMERS.
SECOND -- I BROUGHT THIS CASE --
OF THE FIRST ATTORNEY TO BRING A
CASE OR THIRTY ONE FOR NINETY
BECAUSE I'D AN EIGHTY SIX YEAR
OLD HOMELESS VETERAN CLIENT.
WHO HAD NO REDRESS HIS PERSONAL
AND IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION WAS
TRANSMITTED TO THE DMV
IMPROPERLY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPOSING A WHOLE?
UNDER THIS STATUTE SEVERAL
CALIFORNIANS ARE IN JEOPARDY
BECAUSE THEIR CARS CAN BE TAKEN
BY THE USE OF THEIR P. I UNDER
THE AMENDMENTS -- MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY LOOK AT SECTION I
AM VERY CONCERNED THAT THAT
PROVISION AND LEADS A LARGE
LOOPHOLE THAT ANY OPERATION OR
MANAGEMENT.
CAN INCLUDE SENDING P. I. FOR
ANY PURPOSE.
SO WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT I
IN MAKE SURE THAT'S ADDRESSED
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT TI AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT IS ADDRESSED --
SECOND A TO ADDRESS SECTION FOUR
OH TWO FIVE FOUR OF THE
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE.
THE REAL CONCERN HERE IS THAT --
THEY THE TOLL ENTITIES WANT TO
SEND INFORMATION TO A RELIABLE
PARTY.
BUT THAT BEGS THE QUESTION AS TO
WHO THAT PARTY WILL BE AND WHAT
THE DATA WILL BE USED FOR
SENATORS TO MILLIONS BILL I HAVE
THE LEGISLATIVE HISTORY WAS NOT
JUST ABOUT MARKETING.
IT WAS ABOUT THE USE OF TRAVEL
PATTERN DATA IN HERE THERE'S A
REAL CONCERN THAT DRIVERS
INFORMATION IS BEING -- IMPROPER
CREDIT IN CORY'S -- THROUGH
LEXIS NEXIS EXPERIAN OTHER
COMPANIES AND THIS EXISTING
LEGISLATION WOULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR FORWARD LOOKING
CONSUMERS. TO ADDRESS THE MIS
USE OF THEIR PI WITH THAT WE
REQUEST ON BEHALF OF TAXPAYERS
IN THE CLASS THAT THE VOTE NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE --
RICHARD HALL OVER WITH THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION CALIFORNIA
FIRST I DO WANT TO THANK.
US UNDER ALAN AND AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR A LOT OF GREAT
WORK YOU'VE DONE NARROWING THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL ADDRESSING
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
WE DO STILL CONTINUE HAVE
CONCERNS AND THAT'S WHY WE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
OF AS ADDRESSED EARLIER.
THERE ARE CHANGES TO CURRENT LAW
THAT ARE STATED TO BE
DECLARATORY OF CARTON LAW THAT
WILL IMPACT PENDING LITIGATION
AND AS A PUT GENERAL POLICY
MATTER I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE APPROVED BY
THIS COMMITTEE -- THEY INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE -- AND WE WORK WITH
SENATORS MERION AND AND TWENTY
TEN WE WORKED WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY TEN TO
ELIMINATE ALL THE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WHICH HAD TO DO AROUND
RETENTION OF DATA.
OF THE LENGTH OF TIME FOR
RETENTION BUT AS AS CURRENTLY
AMENDED ANY PERSONAL INFORMATION
THAT WAS IN THE POSSESSION OF
THE AGENCY TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
ELEVEN IS NOT PROTECTED BY THE
WRITTEN CONSENT OF OF THE
CONSUMER TO USE OR SHARE THAT SO.
THAT WILL CERTAINLY IMPACT OF
CURRENT LITIGATION IN A VERY
NEGATIVE WAY.
AND WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED WITH
IRTY ONE FOR NINETY THAT
ELIMINATES RESTRICTION ON OF THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION WITH
THIRD PARTIES BECAUSE IT DEFINES.
WHICH ARE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
AND ANY CONTRACTOR FOR ANY
SUBCONTRACTOR AT ANY LEVEL AS
CONSTITUTING THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY THEREFORE.
THERE IS NO SHARING WHETHER IT'S
WITH THE JANITORIAL FIRM OR OF
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCY OR BIG
DATA OR ANYONE ELSE THEY ARE NOW
ALL CONSIDERED TO BE A
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL WHICH MEANS
THEY'RE NOT SHARING.
SO THAT IS A MAJOR CHANGE IN IN
TERMS OF CURRENT CONSUMER
PRIVACY PROTECTION.
AND OF THE THIRD POINT HAS TO DO
WITH.
US SECTION. THIRTY FOUR ONE FOUR
NINETY C..
VIOLATION INFORMATION IS ALREADY
COVERED.
OF IN CURRENT LAW OF IT CAN BE
RETAINED UNTIL EITHER FOR YEARS
AND SIX MONTHS HAVE HAVE PASSED
WORD TOLD THE VIOLATION HAS BEEN
RESOLVED BUT THIS MOVES IT TO A
DIFFERENT SECTION.
SO VIOLATION INFORMATION NOW CAN
BE RETAINED INDEFINITELY AND WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
PROTECTIVE OF THE PRIVACY OF
CONSUMERS SO.
THOSE ARE OUR OUR MOST ARE
EVIDENT CONCERNS BUT WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED WITH THE METHODS THAT
ARE DESCRIBED FOR OBTAINING.
AN ACCURATE ADDRESS BY ALLOWING
ANY SOURCE TO BECOME.
A RELIABLE SOURCE THAT COULD BE
AN INTERNET SEARCH YOU GET AN
ADDRESS YOU SEND A NOTICE TO
THAT ADDRESS AND IN EFFECT THE
AGENCY HAS DONE ITS JOB WE DON'T
THINK THAT IS A SUFFICIENT
BURDEN.
ON AN AGENCY TO TRACK DOWN THE
ACTUAL ADDRESS OF A OF A
CONSUMER BEFORE VERY HARSH.
PUNITIVE.
ACTIONS ARE TAKING INCLUDING A
POUNDING THEIR VEHICLE PUTTING
LIENS ON THEIR VEHICLE OVER
REVOKING THEIR LICENSE.
SERVED WITH WITH -- WITH RESPECT
TO THE IMPROVEMENTS WE STILL ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ADDITION OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION PLACE. TO
BE AN ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
ALREADY MADE GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT LOOPHOLES THAT ARE
STILL IN THE BUILDER AND OPPOSE
MONTH AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
ROSE MERRY SHE HIM PRESERVE
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
SAFETY WE CONCUR WITH THE OTHER
COME OPPONENTS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO FAULT.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
BEEN TRAVIS FROM COSTAR GROUP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LIKE LIKE SUPPORT -- STEVE ARE
COMING OFF THE GOLDEN GATE
BRIDGE DISTRICT ALSO ONE EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY CHILD.
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION IS
BRING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMING MISTER
OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATOR
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
WHEN I LOOK AT AMENDMENTS?
IN THE COMMITTEE AND THERE'S
VOLUMINOUS AS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'RE TAKING I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING HARD.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENTTO WORK THROUGH ALL
OF THE ISSUES IS CERTAINLY
COMPLEX TOPIC.
AS YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN WORKING
IN THE SPACES WHILE IN LAST YEAR
I HAD A BILL.
THAT ENACTED SOME CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS WHEN VIOLATIONS FOR
HIGH OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENTS AND
TOLL LANES.
WERE ISSUED.
AND MY BILL REQUIRED AT THAT.
WHEN YOU ISSUE A VIOLATION YOU
ALSO INCLUDE THE PHOTOGRAPHIC
EVIDENCE THAT YOU HAVE OF THE
VIOLATION SO THAT THE CONSUMER?
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THAT --
INFORMATION THERE AND HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE TO CONTEST A VIOLATION
IF IT WASN'T VALID SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
PRESERVING THAT BECAUSE THE BILL
ORIGINALLY IS DRAFTED INCLUDED
IT MODIFIED THAT INCLUDED THE
WORDS OR OTHER EVIDENCE.
AT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
APPEAR TO TAKE THAT OUT BUT IT'S
HARD TO TELL BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENTS.
IN THE COMMITTEE REPORT ARE IN
THE CONTEXT OF CURRENT STATE LAW
NOT IN THE CONTEXT OF YOUR BILL
SO I JUST FIRST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT THOSE THOSE. TWO WORDS ARE
BEING TAKEN OUT YEAH MY I MEAN
I'VE I'VE TALKED MY STAFF A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT -- ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND AND THEY
SAY THAT THEY WORK THIS OUT --
BUT BUT CERTAINLY IF IF YOU
DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH IT'S CLEAR
ENOUGH WILL WORK I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT SEEMS PRETTY
CLEAR TO ME IT WAS JUST A LITTLE
HARD TO TELL.
THE OTHER THING THAT THAT I
THINK IS STILL A PROBLEM IN THE
BILL AND I'M HOPING THAT YOU'RE
OPEN TO FIXING THIS.
IS THAT -- US ANOTHER SECTION OF
YOUR CONCERNS THE CALCULATION OF
THE TOLD THE APPROPRIATE TOLL.
AND YOUR ADDING THE WORDS
INCLUDING THE PROPER TOLL AMOUNT
TO THAT SECTION WHERE A WAIT
UNTIL YOU.
WE WILL DEAL WITH THESE ONE AT A
TIME.
YEAH I'M I MEAN I'M I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE FINE WITH TAKING
THAT OUT IF -- IF THE BILL IS
FOR OKAY SO THE THE THE FIRST
THING I THINK THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ALREADY TAKEN OUT
BUT BUT THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENT ABOUT THAT -- IS THIS
THE SECOND -- ONE I THINK IS
STILL IN THE BILL AND I'M HOPING
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE OPEN TO
TAKING THEM OUT -- IT SAYS IN
THIS IS -- BUT SECTION IS THIS.
THIS IS THIRTY ONE FORTY M..
IN THE BILL AND IT READS YEAH
WHAT WILL TAKE THAT OUT.
TO OKAY THE THE WE CLING THE
PROPER TELL ABOUT THAT LIMITING
THE PROPER TOLL AMOUNT AND YOU
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT SEEMS
TO INDICATE THAT WITHOUT ANY
NOTICE TO THE CONSUMER.
A TOLL AGENCY COULD JUST RE
CALCULATE THE AMOUNT AND I I
THINK THAT IF THE CONSUMERS
REPRESENTING SOMETHING ABOUT
OCCUPANCY THAT THEY OUGHT TO GET
A NOTICE OF VIOLATION.
HE ALSO GOT A NOTICE THAT THAT
WOULD THAT THAT'S BEING TAKEN
ALSO THANK YOU FOR THAT
COMMITMENT YEAH.
I PLEASE I MEAN I YOU KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN SUCH A REAL CHAMPION
THIS ISSUE A NUMBER OF YOU I
LOOK AROUND THIS TABLE I'M GLAD
THAT WE HAVE.
ALL THESE PRIVACY CHAMPIONS
AROUND THE TABLE AND SO IT AS AS
MORE OF THESE ISSUES COME UP
PLEASE.
SHARE THEM WITH US AND I WILL
GET THEM ADDRESS THAT YOU KNOW.
I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS FOCUSED ON ON WHAT I SAID THE
BEGINNING WHICH IS.
ALLOWING THEM TO DO THEIR WORK
IN TERMS OF COLLECTIONS THAT
SORT OF THING AND THAT'S IT.
TEACHER DILIGENCE INVESTMENT
WORK ON THE BILL YEAH
[inaudible]
RESPOND QUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THANK
YOU SENATOR ALLEN I THINK THAT
YOUR GOAL HERE WHICH IS TO
PROTECT THE TAXPAYERS MONEY
WHICH THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
GOING TO FIX THE ROADS GOES TO
DO THAT IS -- IMPORTANT ONE I I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND YOUR FOR THE AMENDMENTS I
THINK YOU'RE DRESSED MOST OF MY
CONCERNS ON THE BILL WHICH I
REALLY APPRECIATED -- I THINK IT
IS MUCH BETTER IN ITS CURRENT
FORM -- BUT I DO HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS THE FIRST IS IN MY
BRIEF TENURE HERE ON THE PRIVACY
COMMITTEE I HAVE.
ALL I THINK IN EVERY INSTANCE
SEEN THAT THE DURATION IN WHICH
WE THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
WITH TO RETAIN DATA IS
APPROXIMATELY SIX MONTHS.
THE BILL AND I KNOW THIS ISN'T A
CHANGE BUT HOW WE'RE CHANGING
THE LOS LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
IN THE BILL.
THEY HAVE FOR YEARS AND SIX
MONTHS AFTER SOMEBODY CLOSE AN
ACCOUNT FOR A FINE IS SETTLED
THAT SEEMS LIKE A VERY LONG TIME
FOR THIS DATA BE RETAINED.
HAS ANY THOUGHT BEEN GIVEN TO
AMENDING THAT.
YEAH THE BEN RUBIN YEAH THANK
YOU ADD TO SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE
THE CONCERN THERE WAS THAT UNDER
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
THERE'S A FOUR YEAR STATURE
LIMITATIONS.
AND IN THE LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
CONTRACTORS FOR THE TOLL
AGENCIES THEY'RE STARTING A FOR
YOUR STATURE LIMITATIONS.
IN IF WE ONLY HAVE THE
INFORMATION FOR SIX MONTHS.
AGENCIES WILL BE ABLE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES OF THE CONTRACTORS
AGAINST THOSE CHALLENGES SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S A FOR YEARS AND
SIX MONTHS TIME PERIOD IS
BECAUSE UNDER THEM FOR
COMPETITION LAW.
THE FOR YOUR SEDIMENTATION.
AND IF WE WOULD BAR ALL CLAIMS
AGAINST TOLL AGENCIES OR THE
CONTRACTORS UNDER THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW.
WE WOULD NEED THAT TIME PERIOD
BUT IT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
SERVING THOSE CHALLENGES THAT'S
NECESSARY GOT IT OKAY.
AND THEN I AM.
I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
SECTION. FOUR ZERO TWO FIVE BE
WHICH IS THE SECTION RELATED TO
NOTICE TO CONSUMERS ABOUT THEIR
FINES.
SO I WAS RECENTLY DRIVING ORANGE
COUNTY AND NOT BEING FROM ORANGE
COUNTY ENDED UP ON A TOLL ROAD
WITHOUT KNOWING IT DIDN'T HAVE
MY FAST TRACK -- MY HUSBAND WAS
DRIVING AND I THOUGHT OH NO WELL
I'LL JUST GO ON THEIR WEBSITE
AND I'LL PAY THE TOLL.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
THERE IS NO WAY FOR ME TO PAY
THE TOLL PROSPECTIVELY UNLESS I
HAD MY TOLL TAG.
SO HERE I WAS ON A TOLL ROAD
WHICH DIDN'T REALIZE I WAS DOING
IT I HAD TO WAIT UNTIL THEY SENT
ME SOMETHING IN HOPES THAT GOT
TO ME.
SO I WOULD AS I SEE THIS THE
BEST EFFORT WOULD INCLUDE THE
ABILITY TO PAY THE TOLL UP FRONT
TO FIND SOMEBODY WHO'S TRYING TO
DO THAT SO.
I GUESS I JUST SEE THIS AS YOU
KNOW WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS A
PRETTY STRONG THING TO PROVIDE.
AND TO PROVIDE IT WITHOUT MAKING
SURE THAT ALL OF OUR TOLL
PROVIDERS ARE ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
PAY THESE TOLLS IS SOMETHING
THAT MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE.
DO YOU WANT TO SAVE HIS USING I
I MEAN I WAS IN ORDER NOT TO
LONG AGO AND PAID MY TOLL I
DIDN'T HAVE MY FAST I GOT PAID
RIGHT AFTERWARDS BUT IT SOUNDS
AS THOUGH.
YOU'VE GOT THE THERE IS A WAY TO
PAY HEARING IT YEAH MY MY
APOLOGY -- MEMBERS IF OUR
INFORMATION WAS A PERFECTLY
CLEAR BUT DEFINITELY WHEN YOU
USE THAT TOLL ROADS IN ORANGE
COUNTY YOU CAN PAY FIVE DAYS
BEFORE WITHOUT ACCOUNT YOU CAN
PAY FIVE DAYS AFTER.
AND ALSO IF YOU FORGET TO PAY
AND YOU GET A VIOLATION WE HAVE
AN AMNESTY PROGRAM WHERE AS LONG
AS YOU PAY THE TOLL WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS.
ALL PENALTIES ARE WAY TO DO WE
KNOW THAT EVERY SINGLE TOLL ROAD
IN CALIFORNIA I CAN GO ON AND
PAY PROACTIVELY.
I KNOW THAT YOU TO REPRESENT ALL
THE TOLL ROAD SO I'M PROBABLY
ASKING QUESTION YOU CAN ANSWER
BUT I GUESS THAT I WOULD INCLUDE
THAT IN THE DEFINITION RIGHT THE
DEFINITION HERE IS OF YOU
SEEKING OUT BUT I THINK THE
ABILITY FOR CONSUMERS TO GO AND
PAY THOSE TOLLS.
SHOULD ALSO BE INCLUDED.
AND I DON'T I MEAN I YOU
PROBABLY CAN'T FIX EVERYTHING
RIGHT NOW I WOULD EXPECT YOU.
TO AS AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TOLD OKAY I THINK THAT'S A FAIR
QUESTION OKAY -- I DEFINITELY
KNOW THAT ALL THE AGENCIES HAVE
TO AMNESTY PROGRAM THAT I
MENTIONED IN PLACE AND YOU KNOW
WE MIGHT DO IT DIFFERENTLY BUT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES.
AND WE ALL OFFER WAIVERS OF
PENALTIES IN TERMS OF A
PROACTIVE NOTICE IF THAT'S
SOMETHING -- THAT THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO SEE GOING FORWARD
IN WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE --
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE IT WORK -- TO
MAKE SURE IT'S CONSISTENT -- IN
TERMS OF PROCESS ACROSS ALL THE
TOLL FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
OKAY BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S A
CONSUMER WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO JUST GO
ONLINE AND PAY THAT KNOWING I
HAD MADE A MISTAKE RIGHT.
RATHER HAVE TO WAIT FOR NOTICED
COME TO ME BUT THEN AGAIN I MAY
HAVE NOT BEEN AN ORANGE COUNTY
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE SPEAKING ABOUT A DIFFERENT
TORRENT -- AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION -- WAS [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE SO. THIRTY ONE FOUR
NINETY I WHICH IS THE SECTION
THAT RELATES TO THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION -- IT TALKS ABOUT
THE REASON YOU WOULD SHARE IT
RATE -- WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO IN
THE PERFORMANCE OF COLLECTION
AND ETCETERA ETCETERA.
IT DOESN'T TALK ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE SHARING IN THE
PERFORMANCE OF THOSE DUTIES
WHICH IS A CONCERN FOR ME RIGHT
YOU DO YOU HAVE A LOT MORE
INFORMATION THEY NEED THEN IT
NEEDS TO BE SHARED WITH THE DMV
TO PERFORM YOUR DUTIES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
NARROWED SO THAT IT'S NOT JUST
THE YOU'RE DOING IT FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS BUT YOU'RE ALSO
ONLY SHARING THE DATA THAT IS
NECESSARY TO PRODUCE THAT.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T NEED TO SHARE
WITH THE DMV WHAT LANE I WAS IN
OR WHAT BRIDGE I WAS HONORED
CETERA ETCETERA RIGHT IN ORDER
TO GET MY ADDRESS.
YES AND WE DEFINITELY WORK WITH
THE DMV AND IT HERE TO THEIR
STANDARDS IN TERMS OF THE FIELDS
AND DATA WE HAVE TO SUBMIT TO
WORK WITH THEIR SYSTEM.
BUT I I I DON'T SEE YOUR REQUEST
AS UNREASONABLE I THINK IF YEAH
I WANTED TO SEE MORE DEFINITION.
AROUND THAT I THINK LAYING OUT
THE EXACT DATA WE SHARE IN EACH
INSTANCE WOULD MAKE THE BILL
AWFUL ALL RIGHT -- BECAUSE WE
ARE VERY SELECTIVE AND DEPENDING
ON THE PURPOSE.
OF THAT PARTICULAR CONTRACT IN
THE FUNCTION WE DO LIMITED DATA
THATWE WOULD SHARE WITH THEM
JUST LIKE WE DO WITH INTER
OPERABILITY.
RIGHT BUT I THINK YOU COULD DO
SOMETHING LIKE SAY ONLY THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO PERFORM
HIS DUTIES FOR EXAMPLE
[inaudible]
I WHICH IS I WOULD JUST I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT YOU KNOW WE HEAR
IT THE REPAIR REASON WE'RE HERE
IS BECAUSE OF GRAY AREA SOMEONE
WE SITE SOMETHING LIGHT.
AS NECESSARY IS THAT GOING TO
CREATE ANOTHER GRAY AREA WHERE.
ONE GROUP MAY SAY NECESSARY
MEANT THIS AND ANOTHER GROUP.
SAYS NO IT MEANT THIS.
RIGHT WELL MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WEEK THAT SOME OF THE TOLL
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN SHARING MORE
DATA THE NECESSARY WHICH IS WHY
I SAY THIS AND SO I THINK THAT
TALKING ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
SHARED IS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THIS PUZZLE.
WE NOT JUST THE THE PURPOSE OF
THIS YEAR.
ON UNDERSTATEMENT -- EIGHT YOU
KNOW I I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
ASSERTION BY I I DO UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL MISTER ONE GO
AHEAD -- IF I YOU KNOW I I
APPRECIATE SENATOR ALLEN ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE ALREADY DONE
AND THE AMENDMENTS THAT --
YOU'VE TAKEN AND I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY -- BUT
AS WE'VE HEARD I THINK THERE'S
STILL -- ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
AND AND TO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T DEGRADE THE OF
PRIVACY -- THE LEVEL OF PRIVACY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN
TOLL PAYER SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO NARROW THE SCOPE
AND MAKE SURE THAT -- THE
SHARING FOCUSES ONLY ON THE TOLL
COLLECTING FUNCTIONS AND WE NEED
TO HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT THE DATA
IS NOT BEING USED FOR MARKETING
OR NON TOLD RELATED ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER.
YEAH JUST REALLY QUICKLY I MEAN --
ONE I I I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS BILL FORD IN IT AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF WORK HAS
BEEN DONE -- IN WORKING WITH THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS.
BE AWARE I START FROM IS YOU
KNOW WE ARE DEALING WITH AN
INDUSTRY AREA THAT'S ALREADY HAS
THESE TYPE PARAMETERS OF MEN PUT
AROUND IT FROM THIS A MILLION
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED --
IT'S IN IN A WAY ALMOST LOOK IT
THIS IS PROBABLY WHAT A LOT OF
OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
SHOULD HAVE IN PLACE THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE -- AND AND
ENSURE THAT DATA IS NOT BEING
SOLD.
OR YOU KNOW MISUSED.
BUT THIRD PARTIES AND IT REALLY.
WHAT I GET FROM THIS IS THAT
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS TRYING TO
KEEP THIS REALLY TIGHT SO THAT
YOU CAN USE IT FOR ENFORCEMENT --
AND TO ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE DOING WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO IN TERMS OF
PAYING THE TOLLS THAT -- YOU
KNOW AND AND THAT THAT'S NOT
BEING SOMEHOW SUBVERTED AND THE
CONCERN BEING THAT.
UPS BECAUSE OF RECENT
LEGISLATION YOU MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE.
TO YEAH AND AND OBVIOUSLY.
THE LITIGATION THAT HAS
TRANSPIRED -- YOU KNOW SAYING
THAT YOU CAN'T THAT THIS
PROHIBITS YOU FROM SHARING.
WITH THE AND THE FOR EXAMPLE --
YOU FOR A LEAD FOR LEGITIMATE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS SO NEAR
TO ME I SEE IT AS A YOU KNOW A
TIGHT.
FIX -- TO AN ISSUE THAT I THINK
WE'VE ALREADY I MIGHT ASK KAY.
WE KNOW WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH
OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES -- AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HOW
THEIR SH YOU KNOW HOW THEY'RE
SHARING DATA AND AND HOW THEY'RE
VULNERABLE.
I THINK MAYBE WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THEM AS IT
WOULD BE.
MY QUESTION BUT YEAH.
ANYWAY I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY.
MISS WICKS GUY.
YEAH -- THANKS FOR BRINGING THE
BILL -- YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THE SENTIMENT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN MADE AROUND REALLY
MAKING SURE REGARDING PRIVACY
PROTECTING PRIVACY I CAN SEE WHY
WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON THE AMENDMENTS AND
COMPARING THAT SCOPE IN.
YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH TO MOVE THE
BILL FOR TODAY BUT I AM ASKING
YOU TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AS YOUR
NORTH STAR REALLY PROTECT NOT
PRIVATE SIX IT'S GOING GOOD.
VERY CRITICAL AND A LOT OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TO THE
TABLE -- I VALUE THEIR OPINION
IN JUDGMENT ON THE STUFF AND
HOPE THAT YOU CAN CONTINUE THE
THE CONVERSATION WITH THOSE THAT
ARE OPPOSING. TWENTY ALSO THANK
THE SENATOR AND HIS TEAM FOR
WORKING WITH US -- THE LAST FEW
WEEKS -- ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO I
I HAD A CHANCE TO MEET WITH BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE AND IN IN MY
OFFICE IN AND TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT I CAME UP WITH AT THAT
POINT WAS -- THERE'S NO WAY THAT
IS GONNA YOU KNOW -- BE TAKEN OF
THIS YEAR I HAD TO BE A TO YOUR
BILL.
NOW SINCE THEN -- WE CONVENED A
STAKEHOLDERS MEETING OBVIOUSLY
ABOUT BY BRINGING BOTH SIDES
TOGETHER.
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT -- YOU
KNOW.
WE ALL SAT DOWN AND TALKED AND
THE TEAMS THAT IS.
OUR AND DO YOU KNOW WE'RE MUCH
CLOSER THAN WE WERE THREE THREE
WEEKS AGO AND AS MENTIONED -- AS
WE HEARD EARLIER.
ALL THE SENATOR HAS ACCEPTED A
LOT OF IN FACT ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT'S BEEN THE
PROPOSED.
ON AND I THINK -- THE AMENDMENTS
GO QUITE A BIT OF A WAYS --
IMAGES SHARE SOME THOUGHTS WITH
YOU ON OUR ON WHERE I AM ON THE
BILL.
I THINK SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
SEARCH BEEN TAKEN ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS --
TO REVOKE CONSENT.
ARE TO HAVE THEIR INFORMATION
SURE FOR MARKETING PURPOSES AND
ALSO IMPROVING HOW THE AGENCIES
DETERMINE.
THE INDIVIDUALS ADDRESS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SENDING A VIOLATION
NOTICE.
YET.
THERE ARE STILL OTHER PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL THAT ARE STILL
PROBLEMATIC -- IN MY VIEW -- AS
APPLIED RETROACTIVELY AND ALL
SOUL PROSPECTIVELY.
OUR SPECIFICALLY THE BILL EVEN
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ALLOWS
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO SHARE
THE INDIVIDUAL'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION WITH ANY CONTRACTOR
HAS BEEN MENTION.
OF FOR THE OPERATION AND
MANAGEMENT OF THE TOLL
COLLECTION SYSTEM.
THIS IS -- AN EXPANSION OF WHAT
IS SO ALLOW UNDER EXISTING LAW.
NOW APPLY PROSPECTIVELY I HAVE
CONCERNS THAT AGENCIES WOULD NOT
BE INCENTIVIZE TO LIMIT THE
SHARING OF PERSONAL INFORMATION.
OF WHAT IS NECESSARY -- TO
COMPLETE A TASK.
NO THIS COULD RESULT IN NOT A
LARGE DATABASE FULL OF
INDIVIDUALS PERSONAL INFORMATION.
ARE NOW IS AS THE CO AUTHOR OF
THE THE PRIVACY BILL THAT WE
PASSED LAST YEAR THAT THE CCPA.
I HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT --
BUT I'M I'M EVEN MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE RETROACTIVE
APPLICATION OF THE BILL.
OUR FIRST AHA I BELIEVE THAT
LEGISLATION SHOULD APPLY
PROSPECTIVELY.
ARE TO AVOID ANY -- TO AVOID.
INTERFERING WITH ANY PENDING
LITIGATION.
WHEN APPLIED RETROACTIVELY I'M
CONCERNED AT THIS EXPANSION?
OF WILL ALLOW INTO THESE THAT
HAVE WILEY TO THE LONG TO OF
AVOID BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE VIOLATIONS.
AND EVEN WORSE SO WILL PREVENT
INJURE THE PARTIES FROM SEEKING
REDRESS.
I'M I THINK -- THE PROPONENTS
HAVE ARGUED THAT MANY OF THESE
PLAINTIFF SUFFER NO HARM AND
AGENCIES ACT WITHIN THE SPIRIT
OF THE ORIGINAL.
LEGISLATION.
NO I THINK THAT IF IF THERE ARE
TRULY FRIVOLOUS CITATIONS BEING
FILED.
I THINK THE PROPER PLACE -- TO
DISCERN OR ADJUDICATE WOULD BE
WOULD BE ALL IN THE COURT SYSTEM.
INSTEAD OF REWRITING THE LAW.
ARE THERE IS NOT TO SAY THAT --
UNLIMITED LIABILITY FOR TOLL
AGENCIES IS NOT A PROBLEM.
OUR MILLIONS OF TAX PAYERS
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN INVESTED IN
THAT WHOLE ROSE AS WE HEARD.
ALL AND MANY OF US RELY ON THEM
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT --
ANY RETROACTIVITY ARE THAT WE
TAKE ON SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
JUST AMENDMENTS THAT TRULY
CLARIFY THE LAW AND DO NOT WATER
DOWN.
ANY RIGHT SO THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR ANY CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ALL INTENDED TO IN THE SOME
INDIAN LEGISLATION.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT -- I I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TO MOVE
IT FORWARD IF I HAVE THE
SENATORS COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS I THINK
EARLIER YOU INDICATED THAT YOU
WOULD DO SO.
SO I THINK THERE ARE STILL
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO KIND OF
FINE TUNE GOING FORWARD.
BUT BUT I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT
IT AND YOU KNOW CAN I ASK YOU TO
BE MINDFUL OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
I MENTIONED -- REGARDING
RETROACTIVITY AND YOU KNOW THE
POTENTIAL OF INTERFERING WITH
THE PENDING LITIGATION.
OUR BE MINDFUL OF THAT ICE I
THINK -- WE DON'T WANT TO BE
ACCUSED OF YOU KNOW RIGHT
WRITING LAW OR REWRITING LAWS
THAT WOULD -- IMPACT OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE COURT SYSTEM AND
THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF MY
CONCERNS SO TO FEED IT.
YOU KNOW -- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES IF YOU LIKE IN AN HOUR
AND WE'LL GO FROM THERE.
YEAH I LOOK I APPRECIATE ALL
COMMENTS YOU JUST MAY MISTER
CHAIR I THINK -- IN THE OTHER
DAY I THINK WE'RE VERY MUCH IN
LINE I CERTAINLY GIVE YOU MY
COMMITMENT TO TAKE TO TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THE VERY CLOSELY.
ON BOTH OF THE OPPOSITION -- THE
SUPPORTERS BUT I ACTUALLY I
REALLY DO I'M [inaudible]
APPRECIATE.
THE THE THE THE ENGAGEMENT OF
YOUR COMMITTEE -- COMMITTEE
STAFF -- I DO I DO THINK YOU
PARTICULARLY GIVEN YOUR
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE WITH THE
PRIVACY BILL LAST YEAR IS AS OR
SEEN AS SOMEONE WHO'S.
GOT A LOT OF INTEGRITY AND A LOT
OF FUN.
A LOT OF OF OF CREDIBILITY ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND I I I THINK YOU'VE HEARD ME
SAY SEVERAL TIMES CONSIDER YOUNG
I REALLY THINK IT BEARS
REPEATING -- THIS REALLY IS
ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT THAT.
IT. TO THE EXTENT THAT WERE
ALLOWED FREDDIE RETROACTIVITY IT
IS SOLELY FOR THE PURPOSE.
OF OF FILLING THAT THE YOU KNOW
WHAT IS TO ME THE CLEAR INTENT.
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND BILL --
WHICH INVOLVES ALLOWING THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES TO DO
THEIR BASIC WORK -- INVOLVING --
TOLD MANAGEMENT IN COLLECTION.
AND ANYTHING BEYOND THAT I THINK
IS A IS NOT WHAT I'M LOOKING TO
DO I WITH THIS BILL AND SO ON
YOU TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
COMMITTEE WANTS.
YEAH I I WOULD LIKE THE
COMMITTEE TO BE HONEST I TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE.
OUR TO THE SENATE THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS OR YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL REFINEMENTS THAT
YOU -- WANT TO MAKE TO TO ENSURE
THAT WHAT I JUST.
STATE IT IS MY CLEAR INTENT --
IS IS IS IS A FACTUAL IN IN IN
IN IN THE FINAL LANGUAGE OF THIS
BILL.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S ALL OUR
EFFORT IS ABOUT -- SO YOU KNOW
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE LITERALLY
BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
IMPERILED ARE BECAUSE OF
TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS -- OF OF OF
BUT OF THE LAW THAT.
ARE THERE THAT ARE THAT THAT ARE
NOT IN LINE WITH THE INTENT.
AS STATED BY SUBMITTING WHEN HE
PUT THE BILL FORD [inaudible]
ON THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S
SOMETHING I REALLY FEEL STRONGLY
ABOUT AS BOTH THE TAXPAYER AND
IS A USER OF OF TRANSIT IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE --
BUT BUT ALL THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE MADE ABOUT PRIVACY I CARE A
LOT ABOUT MYSELF I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S AN ABSOLUTE NO
IMPACT ON THE CPA -- AND YOU
KNOW I INVITE THE COMMITTEES YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO ENGAGEMENT.
ON THIS BILL IF IT GETS OUT
TODAY -- TO ENSURE THAT THE
INTENT THAT I TO STATUS.
IS -- IS CASE CLEARLY EFFECTUATE
A MAP AND IN THE FINAL PRODUCT
HERE.
VERY GOOD WITH THAT -- WAS AT
YOUR CLOSER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY SOMEWHERE.
I NEED A MOTION.
THIS THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED SO IF YOU FEEL YOU KNOW
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE WELL WE
BROUGHT TOGETHER YOU KNOW
POLITICIANS LAWYERS AND TOLL
OPERATORS THROUGH THE MOST
POPULAR.
TYPES OF PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S QUITE ACHIEVEMENT AND
I I I KNOW I I I REALLY DO YEAH
YOU GUYS ARE THE MOST POPULAR
TOLL. TO OPERATORS.
I GUESS YEAH.
WE FINALLY FOUND A GROUP IT'S
LESS POPULAR THAN LAWYERS.
I'M A LAWYER I'M ALIVE.
I KNOW BUT I I I I REALLY DID
YOU FOR ME THIS IS ABOUT --
LEADING OUR OUR TRANSIT AND
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES.
DO THEIR WORK.
AND THAT'S ALL THIS IS ABOUT.
AND SO I I'VE HEARD ALL THE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE WE'RE
GONNA YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I'D
ADDRESS ISSUES RAISED BY SUMMER
OBERNOLTE -- I THINK THIS
PERSPECTIVE PAYING ISSUE IF WE
NEED TO MAKE IT CLEAR ON THE
WEBSITES AROUND THE STATE WE
OUGHT TO DO THAT -- YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF I I'M I'M HEARING THIS
KIND OF DEBATE ABOUT HOW WE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH WE SPECIFY.
INFORMATION THAT THAT THAT CAN
BE SHARED -- I MEAN I I HEAR YOU
BUT THE SAME TIME I YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU'RE HEARING FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT THE NEED TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER INFORMATION
IS HERE IT IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY FOR THE PROPER
FUNCTIONING OF THE OF THE
TRANSIT AGENCY SO WE NEED. TO TO
FINESSE THAT LANGUAGE AND GET IT
TO A A GOOD PLACE -- AND I I
ALSO HEARD ALL THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE ANOTHER
KIND OF SWEEP OF THIS BILL GO
THROUGH THE VARIOUS ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED.
AND AND JUST ADDRESS EVERY
SINGLE THING WE POSSIBLY CAN --
YOU KNOW I WILL SAY THE
OPPOSITION I THINK YOU FOR ME
SEE OVER AND OVER AGAIN I I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO DO THEIR WORK.
BUT BUT BUT YOU KNOW THE THE
PRIVATE INFORMATION CANNOT BE
USED FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSES FOR
MARKETING.
AND CANNOT BE USED FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT GO BEYOND -- IT
THE THE THE CORE FUNCTIONS OF
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
WITH THE OPERATION.
OF THESE TOLL ROADS AND SO ON SO
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP
KEEP JUST HAMMERED AWAY GOING
INTO THE DETAILS WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
WORKING WITH WHATEVER MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE WANTS TO ENGAGE --
AND AND AND AND GET TO A PLACE
THAT WE FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE TO ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY -- WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAO HI CHAO
AYE KILEY OUR QUE HAN.
BARRICADE CAN I BERMAN BERMAN I
CALDERON.
CALDERON I GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I IRWIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE FIVE SMITH.
SMITH I WICKS.
WICKS I YOUR BILL IS OUT THERE
ARE EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU BELIEVE
THE ROLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SHAME ECONOMIST RENDON
[inaudible]
SO
.
THIS IS MY LIFE [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE RARE OCCURRENCES OF YEAH.
SO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ON
NUMBER [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH
[inaudible]
IT IS.
AND
YEAH
.
THESE ARE.
SMALL [inaudible]
MORE [inaudible]
STAFF
[inaudible]
THE
ON SOME OF
YOUR
ONE ARE
[inaudible]
THE
p[inaudible]
APOLOGIZE RIGHT.
AND THEN I JUST.
USE WORDS.
ALL RIGHT I DO WAY BETTER STERN.
SB SEVEN THIRTY I DO PRESENT
WHEN YOU'RE READY YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- APPRECIATE.
YOUR TIME APOLOGIES FOR THE
DELAY MEMBERS -- FIRST ONE WE
THINK THEY COMMITTEE STAFFER THE
DIALOGUE AND TRY TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THE ISSUES -- SO THE THE
THE AMENDMENT -- THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WRESTLING WITH IT I KNOW WE'RE
STILL TRYING TO SORT OF WORK
THIS THROUGH WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND THERE'S STILL SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES SO -- WE WANT
TO TAKE IT INTO ACCOUNT GOING
FORWARD BUT I FROM OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CHAIR
SOUNDED AMENABLE TO LEAVING THAT
ASIDE FOR THE DAY AND THEN SORT
OF WORKING ON THAT ISSUE OF WHAT
EXACTLY -- WHICH WAY AN EQUITY
STAKE FLOWS -- SHOULD BE
RESOLVED TO APPRECIATE THAT UP
FRONT I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR.
THE CALIFORNIA HOME OF TECHNIQUE
[inaudible]
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION AND THERE
ARE HUGE HUGE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
BEEN A MALE AVAILABLE TO US TO
LIVE OUR LIVES MORE CONVENIENTLY
TO ACCESS OUR DATA WHEN EVERYONE.
THROUGH THE CLOUD OF FINDING
CONVENIENCE IS OUR DAILY LIVES
BUT THERE'S ALSO CHALLENGES THAT
GO.
WITH THE GROWTH OF THIS
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL SECTOR --
AND THOSE MAY ENTAIL NOT JUST
ISSUES AROUND LABOR AND
AUTOMATION WHICH WE'VE SEEN MANY
TIMES THE LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO
IN TERMS OF ISSUES AROUND A
PRIVACY THAT WE'VE SEEN ELEVATED
THIS YEAR WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
HERE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE --
AND ALSO ABOUT THE VALUE OF
OURSELVES AND OUR DATA INTO THE
SYSTEM -- A PERSON CAN'T BE
REDUCED INTO JUST DOLLARS AND
CENTS BUT RIGHT NOW THE WAY WE
INTERACT WITH TECHNOLOGY -- WE
ARE QUANTIFIED IN THAT WAY AND
SOME INTERNAL PROCESS THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL IS REALLY TO TRY TO
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY WHICH
DOESN'T JUST LIVE IN THE CLOUD.
WAS HERE ESTABLISHING CALIFORNIA
AS THEIR HEARTLAND TO TAKE MORE
OF AN EQUITY STAKE IN SOME OF
THE COST BUT ALSO THE BENEFITS
OF INNOVATION.
AND REALLY TRYING TO THINK
THROUGH A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH AS OPPOSED TO JUST
TRYING TO LEGISLATE.
SOME SOLUTION TO GET THE SAME
KIND OF DILIGENCE BEING DONE
AROUND THE FUTURE OF WORK BY THE
GOVERNOR NOW -- INTO A SORT OF
BROADER QUESTION THAN JUST --
IMPACTS ON LABOR MARKETS SO TO
BE THINKING ABOUT -- IMPACTS ON
HOUSING -- ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ON DEMOCRACY I NOTE -- CHAIRMAN
BERMAN WITH THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING ON CYBERSECURITY ISSUES --
JOURNALISM IS COLLAPSING IN MANY
CASES WE HAVE NEWS DESERT'S
EMERGING ALL OVER THE PLACE --
IT'S AND IT'S ONE THING TO PLAY
THE BLAME GAME BUT IT'S ANOTHER
TO ACTUALLY SOLVE THE PROBLEM SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS
COMMISSION CAN ACTUALLY COME UP
WITH SOME PROACTIVE SOLUTIONS TO
DEALING WITH SOME THESE BIG GAPS.
THEY WERE FACING -- IN
CALIFORNIA AND MAYBE IF WE
BECOME A SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY SCALE THIS TO COVER THE
REST THE COUNTRY -- SO HOPEFULLY
THIS COMMISSION -- SETS A
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE GIVES
LEGISLATURE A HEAVY HAND IN
DECIDING THOSE OUTCOMES AND
COMES BACK TO US -- WE SOME OF
FEEDBACK THAT WE CAN MOVE ON IN
THE FUTURE YEARS -- I WANTED TO
OFFER TESTIMONY FROM AERIAL FOX
JOHNSON HERE WITH COMMON SENSE
MEDIA AND A HAPPY TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I WOULD I WOULD SAY KEEP IT
BRIEF AND BASED ON THE DON'T
TALK PASS YES.
GREAT -- R. F. I. TONSON WITH
COMMON SENSE MEDIA NATIONAL
NONPROFIT ADVOCATING FOR HEALTHY
DIGITAL ECOSYSTEM WE REPRESENT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED MILLION
PARENTS FAMILIES STUDENTS AND
EDUCATORS ACROSS THE NATION WHO
WANT TO LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE
THEY CAN HARNESS THE POWER BE
AND TECHNOLOGY. FOR LEARNING IN
LIFE.
TAX REFORM MEANS MORE THAN JUST
PROTECTING PERSONAL INFORMATION
OBVIOUSLY WE THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT AS CO SPONSORS THE
CCPA.
TECH COMPANIES ARE BENEFITING
FROM A DATA CONNIE AND THEY NEED
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH DISPLACEMENT AND
GROWING INCOME INEQUALITY.
WE FEEL THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THEM TO CONTRIBUTE TO
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT COMPROMISING
INDIVIDUALS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO PRIVACY PRIVACY.
TECH COMPANIES PROFIT OFF OF US
THEY SHOULD BE PAYING BACK TO
SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS AND
NEIGHBORHOODS.
CORPORATE PROFITS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING MY TECH COMPANIES ARE
AN ALL TIME HIGH.
BUT THE PORTION OF TAX REVENUE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED FROM
CORPORATIONS AS CLOSE TO ITS
LOWEST POINT AND FORTY YEARS.
THEY HAVE TO BE ACCOUNT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE IMPACT OF
MISINFORMATION THE MANIPULATION
OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
AND THE THREAT THAT THEY COULD
POSE TO OUR FREE PRESS.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE WORLD'S MOST
INNOVATIVE TECH COMPANIES
WORKING ON SOLVING SOME OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES OF OUR TIME WILL
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY THAT MAKES
OUR LIVES AFER HEALTHIER AND
MORE CONNECTED.
BUT AS WE SEE MANY OF OUR
NEIGHBORS UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE OPPORTUNITIES CREATED BY
THIS INNOVATION ECONOMY WE THINK
IT'S TIME FOR TECH TO GET BACK
THEY SHOULD CREATE NOT LIMIT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND THAT IS WHY WE
NEED AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT.
EQUITY MEANS AS IT RELATES TO
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENT.
THROUGH THIS ACT WE HOPE TO
EXPLORE TAX IMPACTS ON
INEQUALITY OUR WORKFORCE THE
FUTURE OF A FREE PRESS AND TAX
IMPACT ON OUR DEMOCRACY AND
SOCIAL CAPITAL.
THIS WILL HAPPEN BY ENGAGING THE
COMMUNITIES AND SECTORS MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THIS AND
WITH THE MOST AT STAKE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND WAS SENATOR
START TO REALIZE A JUST AND
EQUITABLE TECH FUTURE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANKS FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER --
THANKS COMMON SENSE MEDIA FOR
BEING A PART OF THIS --
GRAPPLING WITH SOME REALLY
VEXING ISSUES HERE A LOT OF A
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES I
THINK WE HAVE IN THE STATE --
LOVE THE BILL OF A FORD WOULD
LIKE TO BE CALLED HER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I JUST HAD OBSERVATION I I'D
BEEN STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT
WITH THIS BILL SENATOR AND IT'S
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IN THE
BILL.
I THINK THAT THAT KIND OF EQUITY
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- INCOME
INEQUALITY AS YOU POINT OUT HAS
GOTTEN WORSE THROUGH THE
TECHNICAL REVOLUTION.
AND I'VE SAID BEFORE THAT I
THINK IT'S THE DEFINING
CHALLENGE OF OUR GENERATION TO
TRY TO DRESS THAT INEQUALITY
SOME VERY SUPPORT OF THOSE
THINGS BUT I'M A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH POINTING THE
FINGER AT THE TECHNICAL
REVOLUTION.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES
BECAUSE?
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC DATA.
THE TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN THE
GREATEST ENABLER OF THE CLASSES
OF PEOPLE THAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP IN ALL OF
HUMAN HISTORY.
YEAH AND IF YOU DEFINE.
EMPOWER MEN NOT JUST AS INCOME
INEQUALITY BUT ALSO AS EQUITY
AND YOU COMPARE IT TO THE
INDUSTRIAL REVOLUTION WE HAVE A
LOT MORE EQUITY NOW THAN WE DID
DOWN.
BECAUSE BACK THEN YOU HAD
FACTORY OWNERS WHO JUST BY
ACCIDENT OF BIRTH.
WERE ABLE TO COMMAND THESE HUGE
RETURNS ON THEIR WORKERS GOT
NOTHING WHEREAS IN TECHNOLOGY
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT -- IT'S
MUCH MUCH MORE BROADLY BASED NOW
IT IS TRUE THAT.
IT TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE WINNERS
AND LOSERS BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY
REQUIRES KNOWLEDGE AND TRAINING
TO EMPLOY AND THEREFORE THAT
CREATES THAT ANY QUALITY BUT
THAT'S A MUCH MORE COMPLEX AND
NUANCED ISSUE AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHY I'M A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
WITH THE BILL BUT A VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IT AND JUST ONE
LAST COMMENT IN YES BUT I HATE
TO BE A LITTLE CYNICAL BUT WE'RE
ALL IN GOVERNMENT HERE -- YOU
KNOW WE WE SEEM TO BE IMPLYING
WITH THIS LEGISLATION THAT MORE
GOVERNMENT AND INTERVENTION
REGULATION IS GOING TO MAKE THE
SITUATION BETTER -- BECAUSE NO
ONE HAS EVER FAILED TO BE
TRUTHFUL.
SO SO THAT'S ANOTHER TO PIECES
SKEPTICISM THAT I HAVE BUT I
KNOW YOUR HEARTS IN THIS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE MY HEART'S WITH YOU
I JUST I JUST STRUGGLE A LITTLE
BIT WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION.
I I APPRECIATE THAT -- MISTER
VICE CHAIR YES -- AND I DO I
DON'T WANT THE THESIS OF THIS
LEGISLATION TO BE ONE OF
ACCUSATION AND I ACTUALLY I'M
I'M OPEN TO THINKING THROUGH
WITH YOU.
HOW TO CAPTURE -- REALLY
ACCURATELY THE THE BENEFITS
THEY'RE OF OF DEMOCRATIZING
ECONOMIC POWER THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- MY SENSE IS
THAT THE INDUSTRY ACTUALLY WANTS
TO STEP UP AND TRY TO TAKE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT ROLE YOU LOOK
AT SOME OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE COME OUT COMPANIES LIKE
MICROSOFT -- AND SOME OTHER
LEADERS IN THE FIELD -- THEY'RE
ANXIOUS TO FIND A BETTER VENUES
IN THE CURRENT SORT OF CAT AND
MOUSE GAME THAT WE'RE PLAYING OF
SHUT IT ALL DOWN OR AUTHORIZED
EVERYTHING SO I'M HOPING TO FIND
THAT SWEET -- BUT I APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS AND FEEL ALLOW ME
TO TREAT THAT AS MY CLOTHES ARE
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAO KILEY.
OUR QUE HAN BARRICADE HAND I
BERMAN.
I CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I IRWIN -- WHEN I
OBERNOLTE?
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING.
SMITH.
WICKS.
WICKS I YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY YOU WANNA CALL
THE ROLL ON SB SIX SIXTY FOUR
AND CONSENT JUST IN CASE PEOPLE
ARE HERE [inaudible]
OR THE MOTION WAS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I KILEY.
KILEY AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I?
BUT I'M SECTOR WOULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
CONSENT PLACE.
FILE ITEM THREE S. C. R..
FORTY FOUR MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR THE TERM
RUNNING AYE KILEY.
HI.
KILEY I'D BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I I KNOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
FILE ITEM TO SB.
SEVEN THIRTY THE MOTION WAS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CHOW.
CHOW I KILEY.
KIND OF THE KIND OF A LONG.
YEAH WE GET. ONE IS ON A
THURSDAY.
THE SECOND HALF.
YEAH NOW WE CAN GET KILEY NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
HELLO
YEAH.
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU